welcome to exploring computing
today's video is creating web pages
forms for inputs so
so far we've been looking at how to
present information on a web page
but websites do more than just allow the
presentation
information they actually allow
interaction between a
viewer and the website itself and so in
order to do this
we need to use forms and so
in this video we're going to show you
the basics on how to create forms
so here are a number of different forms
here the top
form is amazon search
and then we have the new york times
searching for articles
we have the weather channel looking up
for weather and then we have
uh google maps asking for food delivery
and this one's a little bit more
complicated than the other ones because
you can see
we can select some pull-down menus here
to
limit our options by their cuisine or
the hours are open or some other options
as well
farms can get much more complicated so
on the left we have the
advanced search form for books at the
stanford library and you can see we've
got all sorts of things we can check
and then on the right we have a creation
of a new account at hbo so
this is the sort of thing we're talking
about we're talking about how to allow
the user to enter information on a web
page and submit it to the web server
now in this class we're going to be
focusing on
how to actually create the web page in
order to submit the information rather
than
how the server itself is going to
respond to that information uh cs106e
students we are going to take a bit of a
look at
exactly what happens to that information
once it gets submitted to the server
uh cs105 students as always i'm going to
go ahead and put those lectures up
at some point later this quarter after
you guys have a little bit of
programming experience under your belt
if you want to take a look at those
okay so here's our sample form here um
we're
allowing people to provide information
on a trip that the ski club is
going on and you can see there's all
sorts of different
elements that allow the users to enter
in information
and in html terminology these are
referred to as form
elements so this whole item that allows
the user to submit information that is
referred to as a form
and then the actual elements where the
user enters in
information types in text clicks on
buttons those are referred to
form elements that's a html only term
in general these sorts of items are
referred to in computer science as
controls
you may also hear the term widgets so
an html form element is essentially a
control
uh which is appearing on a web page and
so we're going to be putting all of our
controls or our form elements inside of
a
form tag um for now i'm just going to
put an id
on this just so we can identify it we
can maybe do some styling information
or you know if we want to work with this
somehow i need a way of getting to this
and so i can go ahead and use the id for
it
id's not actually necessary there's a
bunch of other attributes which may
appear here
so for example if the user is going to
enter an information into the form and
submit it to the web server
the web server needs to know where the
program responding to it will go
and so there's a variety of other
attributes which would appear in the
form
uh depending on how you're planning to
use it for now we're just going to
concentrate on
and there goes maddie for now we're just
going to concentrate on
having the form tag itself
and the elements that appear inside of
it
we can talk about the different
attribute values that might appear in
the form
at another point in time okay so let's
start off with
the elements up at the top these are
text fields
and these are going to be created by
using the
input tag and we're going to see that
the input tag is actually a
multi-purpose tag which creates a bunch
of different elements that we're seeing
on this web pages
as well as a bunch of other elements
that aren't appearing on this form at
all
and the way the input element works is
we determine exactly what the input
element is being used for
by looking at its type and so that in
this case the type equals text
and so that means that the form will
allow
the user to enter in text into a single
line
uh text field you'll notice that there's
a closing slash here and this indicates
that there is a single tag
instead of a pair with a start and end
tag
and i want to go ahead and give it a
name i've got multiple text fields here
and
when this information gets sent to the
web server the web server needs to know
how to identify
which pieces of information go with what
and so
the name determines how this is going to
be identified by the server when the
information is sent
in addition to the name when the user
enters in
information to the form and clicks on
the submit button
there's going to be a value which is
whatever the user has entered into the
form
and what will happen is the server will
receive the name
and the value as a pair so if
i enter in the word none here uh what
will get submitted to the server is
that the credit field as determined by
the name on that text field
the the server will receive the
information that the credit field has
the value none
now so far our text field has started
out empty
uh you can start off the text field with
a pre-existing value so
you know probably if there's a field for
credit card
the correct answer is not none and so we
might want to start off with a value so
we could start off with the value
one two three four one two three four
um and so the user would be able to
either submit it the initial value
one two three four one two three four
one two three four one two three four or
they would be able to edit it
in addition uh there's another attribute
value pair that you can put
into the input tag called the
placeholder the placeholder gives a hint
as to what's expected
so in this case our hint is enter credit
card number
you may be wondering what the difference
between providing a value versus
providing a placeholder is
and essentially the value is what will
be submitted to the web server if the
user doesn't
enter anything in the field and if they
do click on that field
the value will be the initial value that
they can edit
in contrast placeholder you'll notice
that it's got that light gray color
and if user were actually to click on
the placeholder text
it would immediately disappear it is not
actual in an actual initial value
it's just sort of there as a hint
all right another thing that's important
to note is that if i have the input tag
here
i give it a name remember the name
identifies when this gets submitted to
the server the name identifies
which particular text field is getting
submitted but there's no actual label
that appears to the user
so if i want a label to appear here so
let's say i wanted to say
credit card that's in addition to the
input tag
so you need to include the input tag and
then
whatever formatting you want to do and
whatever labels you want that
is separate again from the
the input element the input element is
just going to create that blank empty
box
you may also run it to the password
input
type and this looks and works very
similar to
the text type uh the difference being
that if somebody starts typing
to a password you will either get these
circles or you will get
asterisks or or some other indicator
that you have been typing
into the password field but you won't
actually see the text
now i should caution you this password
field
is uh less secure than you might think
it protects from somebody looking over
your shoulder and watching what you're
typing but it does not actually protect
the transmission of information as
the text gets sent to the internet so if
you really want to
have your password protected which of
course you do you need to use the https
secure
variant of the http protocol don't just
set the
input type to the password and expect
that that that is sufficient that is
definitely not sufficient
okay so as i mentioned earlier there's a
bunch of different
types of input elements and so our next
type of input element is the check box
and our example from our ski club web
page
is we're going to have a bunch of
dinners
that we're going to provide for people
coming on the ski club trip
and people can indicate whether or not
they want to
have that particular dinner with this
geek club so there's a bunch of check
boxes and they can go ahead and click
as many or as few of the meals as
they're planning to spend with this geek
club
now again as before with the input of
type equals text
there is no label provided so if you
want
you know there's a name friday dinner
but friday dinner
in the input name equals friday dinner
that's actually
information sent to the server that is
invisible to the user
if you actually want an actual label on
the web page telling them what this
little square that they're supposed to
click off on is
you actually need to manually label it
okay now if you want the checkbox to
start off as checked you can do this by
adding the
attribute checked to the input tag
you may also see people starting off the
value
as either just putting that attribute
check there
or putting an attribute value pair
checked equals checked
what is going on there well i mentioned
a couple times that
i generally use a variant of html called
xhtml which has slightly stricter
syntax rules and so there's a bunch of
different syntax roles uh
tags and attributes need to be in all
lower case
uh if you're using the standard rules
you can you know have ch
input with a capital i um you can have
input with a capital i and a capital t
uh you can mix the case on the attribute
names you can get quite a mess and it
will still be legal
one of the rules index.html is that if
you have
an attribute you must have a value so
if we are following strict xhtml rules
and you were to just say
type equals checkbox and then you would
just say checked
with the attribute name with no value
that would actually be illegal on xhtml
so
if we've got an attribute and we don't
actually have a specific value we want
to set it to
the convention is you set it to the name
of the attribute so thus you may see
checked equals checked
in this case i'm going to just violate
the
xhtml rules and just revert to standard
html roles and just put the word check
there i think
students find that a little bit less
confusing okay so those are check boxes
another type of element you'll run into
quite frequently is something called a
radio button here are the radio buttons
that i have on this webpage
i allow people to determine whether
they're planning to
drive up to the ski lodge on their own
if they want to take a bus with the rest
of the ski team or
if they've got a lot of extra cash if
they want to fly up there
and so the user needs to select one of
these different options and in addition
uh they can determine whether they want
their own room or they want a double
room
now one thing that's important to note
is the difference between a
check box and a radio button so on the
left here i've got my check boxes and on
the right i've got my radio buttons
and the difference here is i can check
as many or as few of the check boxes as
i want whereas the radio buttons these
are mutually exclusive
choices it does not make sense for me to
say yeah i want to go on this ski trip
but
i want both a single and a double room
you need to choose either one
or the other in contrast as far as the
meals go
you know it would totally make sense for
me to say i want saturday's dinner and
sunday's dinner or
you know i don't want any of the dinners
or i want all the dinners
and so these check boxes are are all
independent of each other whereas the
radio buttons are mutually exclusive
and you do want to make sure that you
use the correct
type of element for the correct purpose
i definitely have seen a bunch of
amateur web pages where somebody's like
hey i think those round buttons look
really cool so let me go ahead and use
those even though this is not a mutually
exclusive choice
and that actually is one it's confusing
to users but
two it also causes big problems because
the radio buttons aren't designed to
uncheck normally so
so don't do that use the square
check boxes for choices where the user
can
choose as many or as few as they want
and then use the round
radio buttons when you have a mutually
exclusive set of choices
these are called radio buttons because
they're similar to the
buttons on a car radio so let's say i've
got this car radio here
and station 1 is set to rock station 2
set to wrap and station 3 is set to
country
and let's say i'm listening to some rap
and i decide i don't like this song and
i hit the country button what should
happen
should i continue to listen to rap and
listen to country simultaneously so they
both play over the radio at the same
time
no if that that would be weird what
happens is
by clicking one of the other buttons
whether i click the rock button or the
country button
that deselects the wrap station and
selects
my new station and so that's the way
these radio buttons work
when you select one of the choices
whatever the previous choice is
is deselected automatically and you have
a new choice
now another issue that comes up is that
you may have multiple sets of mutual
exclusive choices so
i've got the choice of travel
arrangements and i have the choices of
rooms
and so these are both different
sets of choices they're independent of
each other you know i don't want the
situation where the user says oh
i'm going to i need to select two of
these so i'm going to choose
bus and airplane and leave the room
choices
unchecked that doesn't make sense so
somehow i need to tell the web browser
that the
none bus and airplane are all associated
with each other
and that single and double are
associated with each other and so i do
this
by using the name here so if you look at
the up at the top
i've got the three input elements of
type equals radio for the travel
arrangements and down at the bottom i
have the two choices for
uh the room and notice that the
three up on top all have name equals
travel and the two down at the bottom
saying name
equals room and so that's actually how
the web browser is determining which of
these i can choose simultaneously and
which ones are mutually exclusive
you'll also note that i've got values on
these
and as i mentioned earlier when we were
talking about the text fields
what's going to happen here is the user
is going to select a bunch of different
options here
and then they're going to submit the
information to the web server
and so the name which we were just
talking about a minute ago
not only tells the web browser that hey
these
these sets of radio buttons all work
together as a set of music exclusive
choices
that's also the name which gets sent to
the web server
telling it hey this is the particular
choice that i'm sending to you
and then the value is the value that
goes with that name
so in this case um with the current
selections
what the web server would get is it
would get the information that
travel was set to air and that room was
set to double
i should also mention i think this was
kind of an odd choice but
if you create the buttons as shown here
um using what i've shown you so far
actually none of the buttons are going
to start off checked so you know i said
it was mutually exclusive and it's
certainly true that
you can't choose single and double
simultaneously but it turns out you can
choose none of the above
and the way we've got the web page set
up right now the initial value is none
of them
and so most likely you want one of these
to start off as
checked and so the way we're going to do
that is we are going to
use this attribute checked
and this is the same one that we saw
with the check boxes
and so if you go ahead and create a
radio button and you add in that extra
attribute checked
then it will start off initially with
that
darkened center indicating that that is
the initial choice
i also want to point out that as with
the check boxes and as with the
text fields there's no labels associated
with
these input elements and so you know
i've got that
room choices and single eighty dollars
and double equals forty dollars that's
extra i had to add that
in addition to the input element you'll
also notice i'm creating a line break
there in order to put the room choices
on a different line than my two radio
buttons there
okay another element that shows up on
our web pages is what is
generically referred to as buttons this
particular web page has two buttons
it's got a submit button and a reset
button
and the submit button when the user
clicks on the submit button
all the information in the form is
gathered together
and all those names and values are sent
to the web server
what happens when you click on the reset
button is
all the information the user has entered
gets tossed out
and everything gets returned to its
initial value so what that would mean is
if you had a text field with an initial
value
and the user had replaced that initial
value the initial value would be reset
if you had a check box or radio button
which you would start it off with this
checked and the user had changed those
settings
it would have been returned to the
initial value so that's what reset does
you'll notice that i've got type equal
submit and type equals reset here but
i've also
got value equal submit value equals
reset what's that what's going on here
well it turns out that the web browser
manufacturers don't really agree on what
these buttons say
and they could say lots of different
things and what the value is in the case
of the submit or reset button is this is
actually the text that appears on the
button itself
and so you can see here in firefox and
edge
the if if i don't have a value on these
instead of saying submit it actually
says submit query whereas chrome
says submit and safari ios says submit
so
you know if you want to make absolutely
sure that the text on these buttons
appears the way you want go ahead and
add in a value
in addition to having the submit and
reset types
you can also create a generic button
this isn't going to make sense
when working with a web server but it
turns out that sometimes you're working
without a web server
just 106e students we'll talk about this
another lecture
if you're doing something called
client-side processing you can actually
carry out some scripting in the web
browser without sending the information
to the web server and you would do that
by creating a button
and uh input type equals button
and then again you would give it a value
to say what what should actually appear
on the web page
so these all appear the same to the user
but
they do have different purposes submit
submits the information in the form to
the server reset resets the information
and the generic type equals button
that's going to be used for client-side
scripting okay
another element that is on our ski club
web
page is a select and so
i'm allowing the user to select if they
want a rental package
they might want no rental package they
might want a ski package they might want
to snowboard package
you can tell how long it has been since
i've skied because these prices are
clearly
way to heck off this idea where i click
on something
and then the menu appears this has a
bunch of different names you can hear
this may be referred to as a drop down
list or drop down menu or a pull down
menu
but in html it's this is just referred
as a select
and here's how i actually create it so
you can see that there's a select
tag there's a start and end tag and then
there's a bunch of different options
where the options are their own
individual elements
we want to go ahead and give the select
a name because
this information is getting submitted to
a web server and we need to identify
what what piece of information is being
sent to the server
and then the values that will be sent to
the server
are actually the text that appears
between the options start tag and the
options end tag
and so here what the server is going to
receive is that the rental package is
none
but this can cause some problems because
this works fine for none
but if i switch to ski package
25 it turns out that that is actually
going to get converted to this
ski plus package plus parentheses
percent 24.25
what the heck is that what's going on
here is that we can't
transmit a dollar sign normally uh
through the http protocol so it needs to
get converted and it turns out that
percent 24 is the hexadecimal code which
corresponds to ascii dollar signs so
it gets converted since it's kind of a
little bit messy to work with on the
server and so we can do here
is we can add values to each of the
options
so now i've got value none value ski and
value board
and what would get set is like rental
package none same as before
but instead of key plus package plus
percent 24
25 uh what would actually get sent is
just rental package ski because i set
value equal to ski so you can see that
that that would be a lot easier to deal
with
okay now the way i've got it set up
right now
the initial value that is appearing is
going to be none because that's the
first thing in my list of options
if you want to change that you can let's
say i want
the rental package to start off with the
ski package the way i'm going to do this
is there's a selected attribute and if i
have an
option and i add a selected attribute to
it that will be the initial
element displayed on the web page you
can also set a
size on the select and that will turn
this from a pull down menu
into something referred to as a list box
and so you can see here i set the size
to three
and all three elements are appearing
instead of having a single element
appearing
and the user having to click on that in
order to see what their options are
with the list box which again you create
by setting a size
if you set a size that is smaller than
the number of options
you'll actually get a little scroll bar
there and the user can scroll up and
down to see the options
there's another attribute that i'm not
going to show you
called multiple which actually allows
the user to select more than one item
simultaneously
that needs to be done with the list box
i think it's kind of confusing because
there's no
strong agreement between the web
browsers for how you actually select
multiple items
like you click on one item and then you
want to select the second one do you
do you hold down the shift key do you
hold down the control key it's
it's really kind of a mess i don't
really recommend multiple but you may
run into that on web pages
so if you do see an interface where you
do
see multiple items and the user is
allowed to collect
on more than one of them that's a select
tag with multiple
okay we're almost done with our elements
here
with our form elements here here's one
more this is a text area
the difference between a text area and a
text field is that the text area allows
multiple lines of text whereas the text
field allows only a single line of text
the text area is a little bit odd in
that it's got a start tag
and it must have an end tag if you were
to just have the start tag and then try
and
end it with a closing slash that would
actually be an error so that kind of
raises the question like
what goes between the text area start
tag and the text area and tag
and so the idea here is if you
want to add text that will appear as the
initial value
you're not going to use the value
attribute value pair i'm not quite sure
why not because that that that would
seem logical based on what we've already
seen but
that actually turns out not to work and
be illegal
if you want to put some initial text
into the text area you actually have to
put it between the text area start tag
and the text area end tag
also there's a variety of different ways
to
set the initial size of the text area
i'm going to recommend that if you want
to set an initial size to text area that
you do in cascading style sheets there's
also an html way of doing it
i'm using a bunch of attribute value
pairs in the text area tag itself
all right so that's it for the elements
that we're going to go over i do want to
mention that there are a
bunch of other elements that you can run
into so
you're seeing them being displayed here
there's a number uh
which displays a number and you can see
there's up down arrows that you kind of
sometimes prove as a spinner which you
can increase and decrease the number
with
there's a range uh input type which
creates the slider there's a date
there's a time
and there's a color which if you click
on it opens up some sort of a color
dialog like the color dialog i'm showing
here right
okay that's it for now i'll talk to you
all soon
you